The empire may have fallen,
but my ambitions never wavered.
I am grand Admiral Thrawn,
and my return is inevitable.
Concentrate taken all that is around you.
Let's go again.
I have reason to believe
vampire is still a threat.
We face another war.
Let's begin.
A soccer talent.
Anakin spoke highly of you.
You're ready.
Nice trick.
Got any more?
Ahsoka
Jedi Rebel
Warrior.
But who is she exactly?
We have 30 seconds to find out.
Well, they clock.
Okay.
And begin
A long time ago in a galaxy far, far away.
The brave Jedi was forged
in the battles of the Clone Wars.
Her name was Oka Tano.
She started as a Padawan under Jedi Master
Anakin Skywalker.
Yes. The chosen one who eventually became
Darth Vader.
She was a spy for the fledgling
rebellion and helped defeat the empire.
She has two lightsabers. Amazing.
In our new series,
she faces her past while helping
to prevent the return of a fearsome enemy.
A soldier enlists the help of her friends
who've been running fiercely independent.
Mandalorian Warriors.
And General
Harrison Dula, one of the best pilots
in the galaxy and central member
of the rebellion and her droid chopper.
So going to be
and we'll have a team of parents
exposed an intergalactic fight
for Grand Admiral Thrawn.
Oh, no, not him,
Chopper.
How did I do that?
Rude.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
There's a brand new Ahsoka trailer with a
whole bunch of Star Wars Easter eggs.
So we'll break it all down.
We also learned that they might be doing
The Mandalorian season four
as a small movie
because they want to do it
before the Thrawn heir
to the Empire movie.
I'll explain what's going on with that.
lot of Thrawn going on in this new trailer
and what's happening in the next
couple of years
just in general in the Star Wars universe
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Of course, I'll be doing
episode videos for Ahsoka.
I've got a couple of fun giveaways
that I'll do during those episode videos
to just starting
at the beginning of the trailer footage.
There's a whole bunch of Thrawn teasing
his return, the fall of the Empire,
the way that Dave Filoni called it.
There, referring to the Shadow Council
and what's left of the Empire
as the Remnant Empire.
there's a little bit of trailer footage
where Harrison Dula is trying to convince
the New Republic Center, including man
Mathema, who is on the series
that the Remnant Empire is still a threat,
that it actually exists like this.
Basically her talking about the Shadow
Council from the Mandalorian
that we saw at the end of season
three and Thrawn coming back
mostly Thrawn but also the Shadow Council
still out there to The Shadow
Council was made up of a bunch
of disparate cells of remnant Empire,
people that each had their own ideas
about what to do
with bringing the Empire back
with each had their own agenda.
you probably notice.
One of the funny things about that is it
seemed like they all kind of didn't
like each other
and none of them really like Thrawn
that much either, except for Pelion.
They kept telling the rest of the Shadow
council,
We need to prepare for grand Admiral
Thrawn return.
He's almost here.
Peron's return as heir to the Empire.
he's part of the original Thrawn trilogy.
So, like, he's another big Easter
egg character that they're bringing back,
generally the next couple of years of this
part of the time, like the mando verse
sort of calling it like Ahsoka
as well as the Thrawn movie,
they're adapting the heir
to the Empire storyline
along with Dark Force Rising,
the last of the original Thrawn trilogy.
but I think they'll actually call
the Thrawn movie Heir to the Empire.
Like Star Wars.
Heir to the Empire, they'll be
a lot of changes that storyline.
Oh, explain that in a second, too,
because that gets into
what's happening with Grogu
who Mando in all those characters
too, in The Mandalorian, just in general.
But the whole idea they're teasing here
is that Thrawn has his own ideas
about what he wants to do
with the future of the Galaxy,
and he believes that he can do
a much better job of managing the galaxy
than, say,
like the Emperor, sweep of the Thrawn
doesn't really care about Moff
Gideon for example,
even though we think that he's, he's
probably still alive out there somewhere.
He had all those clones,
don't be surprised if he comes back at
some point in the next couple of seasons,
even though the two of them
don't like each other,
don't care about each other that much,
and think that one another should be
the actual leader of this new empire.
neither one of them,
and probably several of the other members
of the Shadow Council
don't want the emperor to come back
and this is part of the reason
why Thrawn isn't
like your typical type of cult,
like he's an antagonist in the story, but
he's not a traditional type of villain.
He is trying to do good things.
It's just that he's very,
very cold and vicious in his actions.
he's basically trying
to stabilize the galaxy,
but under his thumb,
not because he wants power for himself
like he doesn't really care about that.
he's mostly doing all this
for the benefit of his people,
which is that's
where his first loyalty lies.
He only pretended to serve the Emperor
after Revenge of the Sith in the Clone
Wars.
I'm not expecting him to show up until,
like, the later Ahsoka episodes,
so we might not learn a whole lot
about his people.
That shifts during season one.
like, I think the idea is that trying
to bring Thrawn back using these Jedi's
star maps in his people with Balon school
and obviously Morgan Elsbeth.
but I think part of the idea is they don't
show up at the end of the series
with this giant
new fleet of ships and be like,
Oh, crap, the New Republic is screwed
then like The Mandalorian Season four
or the Thrawn movie, then they'll get into
a little bit of his backstory
in the chess vendor in the trailer.
They have a little bit of Jedi training
with the soldier training Sabine Wren
And it is meant to be a parallel
for Luke Skywalker
being trained by Obi-Wan Kenobi,
wearing his blast helmet.
But because Dave Filoni said
that the Ahsoka series in general is meant
to feel kind of like a samurai film,
like they designed it
to look more like a samurai film.
Ahsoka's made to feel more like a ronin
kind of Jedi The helmet she's wearing
looks more like a kendo helmet,
which is also another deep cut
for the original George
Lucas classic trilogy.
when he originally designed
the whole concept of Jedi fighting styles
and lightsabers, he decided to look
a little bit more like kendo fighting.
Look,
they use two hands to fight this way.
Mark Hamill told a lot of funny stories
about this
when they were making
the original trilogy.
Like by the time
they got to Return of the Jedi,
he's like, George, we could actually make
these fights look way cooler
if we could actually just use one hand
when we're fighting with the light sabers.
But at least back
when they were making those movies,
George Lucas would not where he's like,
No, no, no.
You have to use two hands
to fight with the light saber.
They're meant to be incredibly heavy.
he finally relented on that.
By the time they got to the prequel movies
and let them fight
with one hands on lightsabers
and use two lightsabers,
that's
when they started to develop more Jedi
fighting styles
and wrote them into the canon.
so if you hear
about the traditional Jedi fighting forms,
that's where that originally came from.
when they were shooting the prequels
and they wanted to have more dynamic
looking lightsaber fights
We also see David
Tennant viewing Jedi droids sitting there
watching them this is meant
to be taking place on Ahsoka ship.
I think the idea is that
she's been with him for a while
now, hopefully they'll use his character
to get a lot of the ancient Jedi lore.
he's meant to be over a thousand years old
so he's older than Master Yoda.
a lot of people asking
if there's any connection to the Droid
from Jedi survivor
who's a High Republic Droid antagonist
from Jedi Survivor, was also left over
from the High Republic, too.
the timeline doesn't
quite match up for that.
But there might be some Easter eggs for
the High Republic with Ron's new ships.
This is what the interior of his ships
look like.
The design language does
look a little bit similar
to that droid in the High Republic stuff
from Jedi survivor.
part of the idea with Jedi Survivor,
the sequel that they're working on
right now, Cal Cassius, all that stuff.
I think they want to do that third game
before they introduce him
in the live action,
but then they will introduce him
in live action just because it's so rich.
From a story perspective,
why would you not try and integrate
some of that with the live action stuff?
Remember just who you are.
All right, You're on Kobo.
The logo on the thing is coming.
If you're not scared.
Show me. Focus.
Good.
Now I'm playing baseball.
Right. You will take me to the senator.
Now take me to the senator.
No less risk
All that you get to light sabers.
Technically one.
But I can split them.
You never gave me to write Skater's
that's also one of the reasons why you see
a lot of the Luke Skywalker callixtus
Easter eggs, the promos
that they were shooting for those games
when they were releasing them, like,
oh yeah, we'll do this in live action
at some point too.
Then they have the scenes of both Ahsoka
and Sabine Lightsaber
fighting with Zenyatta in the Inquisitor,
mirrored in that forest.
It seems like the same planet with a jet
eye star
map was just based on the backgrounds.
this last scene of Ahsoka
in Sabine in Ahsoka ship
is also her wearing
a New Republic uniform.
That's what that blue uniform is.
during the earlier trailers
where you see baylan skoll and shin hati
board the New Republic ship
and just mow through
all those New Republic soldiers,
they're wearing
the same types of uniforms,
there might be some grogu,
some mando crossover.
But the whole idea
with The Mandalorian season four movie
that you may have heard in your feeds,
Dave Filoni, Jon Favreau wanted to release
that before the big Thrawn movie
that they're working on.
Like that's the actual movie that
they were hyping up a little while ago
there are a bunch of story arcs and things
that they wanted to set up
before that movie begins.
And it was going to happen
in The Mandalorian season four.
But because of the strike, delaying
everything, they had this timeline.
They want to get the next Star Wars
movie out by a certain date.
they might not have enough time to shoot
an entire regular season
of The Mandalorian for season four,
so they might just collapse
that down to a single movie in speed run.
All the important stuff.
most of that would involve
grogu learning more about the force,
doing more training himself,
getting more powerful.
The Mandalorian clans
continuing to restore
or almost have finished
restoring the Great Forge
in rearming their people
with best armor beskar weapons
probably a crossover
with the Sokka Sabine Hera
the other Star Wars rebels characters
that are debuting in the Ahsoka series
and then pledging their support together.
Like everybody learning
about the threat of Thrawn together.
At least Mando doesn't
really know about Thrawn right now.
Bo-Katan
the Mandalorians also probably don't know
that much about Thrawn coming back,
they know that Thrawn exists
because he faced them during Star Wars
rebels before the events,
the original trilogy.
But they don't know that he's back yet.
So we think the idea is that originally
they planned
at the end of Mandalorian season four
to have a throng crossover
where he shows up with all of his forces
and they all stand together pledging their
support to face them together.
then you pick up with the events
of that Thrawn heir to the Empire movie
with things going crazy
like a traditional Star Wars movie.
there will be multiple seasons of Ahsoka
like they're not going to do
ten seasons of The Mandalorian.
At some point
they will end The Mandalorian Grogu
will go on to more adventures, probably on
whatever future season of Ahsoka
they're on
Let me know if you spotted
any other Easter eggs in the footage
that it didn't talk about in the video.
My episode videos will start posting
real soon after they start releasing them.
There'll be a couple of the bonus videos
before that too,
so leave
all your requests in the comments below
or the big questions about the characters
just in general.
click.
Here for my new Ahsoka,
Darth Vader and Anik and Skywalker video
for their history together and click here
for my new X-Men 97 Teaser Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!